what does seem to be driving to a large
degree the melee phenomenon is this
extreme inflationary situation that
Argentina is facing you mentioned the
top Eduardo triple digit inflation this
is a article I pulled up from Daniel
race Beck at the Cato Institute arguing
that Argentina should dollarize Pronto
and that's also Central to melee's
platform that basically shut down the
Central Bank convert to Dollars allow
people to use cryptocurrency more easily
and down at the bottom of this you'll
see that uh 50 that everyone across the
board seems to rank inflation as the
country's worst problem 59
among the leftist Coalition 67 percent
among the center-right opposition I
assume much much higher among the
Libertarians uh you know I have one last
clip that I'm going to play to kick off
this discussion about uh Central Banking
and malay's plan to dollarize the
economy uh where Malay is is laying it
all out so let's listen to what he has
to say and then Eduardo I'd like to have
you react to the plan that he's put
forward
foreign
porque
porque for social local inflationary
companies
foreign
so first of all I'll just say that he
demonstrates a better understanding more
competent understanding of Bitcoin than
just about any politician that I've
heard talk about it
with the issue of the central bank
that's really the kind of first order of
business for him would be to shut down
the central bank and dollarize the
economy just in case our listeners are
not clear on what that means it means
that U.S dollars would be the accepted
currency in Argentina and it's something
that's been done in other countries
Panama El Salvador I believe Ecuador so
what what are you what do you think
about that aspect of melee's plan
well first of all I would say that uh
Central Bank was created in 1935 with
the idea of lender of Last Resort and
what they really did the politicians in
Argentina they have been financing the
government at the expense of the middle
class and the whole class in Argentina
we had an average rate of inflation of
over 50 percent a year since 1935 we cut
13 zeros to our money and we still this
year will we will have to cut another
two because one dollar right now is 700
pesos three months ago was half of it so
the inflation rate we are we are just in
the process of and the third or fourth
hyperinflation process in Argentina so
the idea of closing the central bank is
very attractive because has been used to
promote government to allow our
opportunity politicians to build I don't
know Versace the Paleo Versace all
around to buy planes and to live a very
good life what Javier is proposing is
the idea of just dollar Ice in the
economy I think if if you are going to
impose another currency I would suggest
that go back to Gold like Murray Robert
suggested just in the mystery of banking
where why dollar and a currency that is
suffering seven eight percent of
inflation per year and also is in in the
hands of some other politicians that
maybe they are not so corrupted as ours
but all but they are always tempted to
print money and you see by the current
deficits you run in the states so I
think what is important is to eliminate
the cursor for so-so the idea of that
you really need to use this money and
melay is in favor of that so he's in
favor of 100 Reserve banking not to Ally
secondary the issue of secondary money
to the banks and I think that's going to
work of course it's going to be tough
just to get out of inflation to a
healthy currency is going to take time
it's not going to be made in one or two
years and let's see the reaction of the
public and of course is going to be
boycotted so the situation is going to
be tough but Argentina cannot live
another year with this hyperinflationary
process where 50 of the population
cannot eat in a country this like
Ukraine it's like Brazil we produce food
and we are very good producers of food
so it's inevitable I think the the
closing of the you will see I think that
because of all these situations you will
see Javier melaye as our next president
let's see if he's allowed to govern and
let's see if he has a career marriage
and he has the character to implement
the good measures and I hope that the
social aspects conservative aspects of
Javier he he he restricts himself to
push legislation uh to Collective
legislation I hope that he really leave
that part aside and he we can enjoy it
after eight years or 90 years of
collectivism a good government for
argentinians we deserve it I think
that's time for us to live a little bit
with a little bit of quiet and peace
could you give us a sense of just what
it's like living under those economic
conditions I mean uh both the
hyperinflation you know Americans for
the first time in my lifetime
experienced some uh inflation that that
we could feel year over year in recent
years but it's nothing like what's going
on in Argentina and your you know a GDP
from I think 2010 to 2021 there was no
grow economic growth so what is it like
uh just day to day
um living under those conditions when
you go to a supermarket they they they
instead of giving you a price you need
to scan because they are changing the
price in some time you have 10 this this
month they say they will have the
inflation rate will be 25 percent so if
the prices are not available
so they give bring the money to you
to the to the place and they you have to
count 300 000 bucks right there you
don't transfer through banks you need to
use cash and of course you can be robbed
you can be so anytime you do a
transaction the whole track says you
don't have credit if you want to buy a
house you need to buy the house cash of
course that's impossible and of course
the whole Commerce is resented by that
it's a cause the economy stops it's like
in Atlas rank when you see that lights
went down and things shrink and people
are unhappy and they everybody works
like this and you have you can you
cannot see a future and people are just
nervous all the time they become manga
crime starts so we need to stop that and
also there is no certainty in prices in
Argentina last year when I was there if
you go to any store nothing has a fixed
price for example if you want to buy
this cup it's all about are you going to
pay it in cash in six payments 12
payments is it going to be with a check
is it going to be with a credit card
it's going to be with a debit card and
depending on that the cup can cost you
one two three ten dollars twenty dollars
so imagine that multiply by everything
in the economy there's no certainty
whatsoever you cannot plan anything in
in that uncertainty
yeah and uh I mean that's it's that
sounds like just a horrific the the
uncertainty you know day-to-day
uncertainty is just one of the worst
things for uh just human Prosperity
human flourishing not to not be able to
know just something as basic as how much
money you're gonna need to spend and you
know budget for that week and hopefully
Javier malay's rhetoric will it if he
wins will will match the reality and and
some sort of you know Market mechanisms
and discipline will be able to like turn
this around for Argentina I do want to
wrap up by zooming out of Argentina for
a moment with
um Gloria this I want to talk about this
Dynamic of socialism Rising causing
economic destruction Paving the way for
the kinds of reactions that you have
expressed concerned about
manifesting as right-wing military
dictatorships which then kind of begins
to cycle over again it seems to happen
continually all over Latin America and I
assume it's a cycle you're trying to
break what do you think the key to
breaking it is and how optimistic are
you that it can be done
I do believe the answer is embracing
individual liberties and economic
Liberties as one like and run said many
decades ago conservatism and obituary uh
they they're far right in Latin America
is mercantilist they don't want free
markets they don't want to discuss uh
drug cartel used to finance socialism of
the 21st century they don't want to talk
about open borders they don't want they
don't want freedoms period they just
want to have their uh private property
protected in ways that were very similar
to the Southern economy of the United
States previous to the Civil War let's
let's understand that right and I
believe that that's not the way that's
why young people go to the left wing
because the left wing has disguised
themselves as feminists LGBT
environmentalists all these flags that
of course they don't defend in reality
right but but young people are attracted
to that my country after three
right-wing governments that have been an
absolute disaster masters of corruption
from Otto Perez Molina Jimmy Morales and
jamate finally because of three really
bad right-wing governments now we have
socialists with Mia and I've been saying
that asan ran you know like conservatism
and obituary guys you know it's gonna
happen to us and people are like no no
the left wing is not going to govern
Guatemala until now it does so I believe
that that's the only way embracing
libertarian ideas and I believe that
what Javier Miller is doing in Argentina
it's a massive opportunity for
libertarianism worldwide to really make
a stance on what is it that we believe
right and defending those ideas like
Hayek did in road to serve them from the
Nazis and the fascists and the
Communists all equally you know not not
uh not just in in one side
hey thanks for watching that clip from
my conversation with Gloria Alvarez and
Eduardo Marti about the rise of Javier
melee in Argentina for the full
conversation click right here for
another clip from that conversation go
right here